the biggest task in learning a language  is acquiring words  you need a lot of words at first you  need some of the key words so that you  can say something and so that you can  understand simple  content in the language but in the long  run you're going to  have to learn a lot of words link makes  that easy trying to learn words from a  list doesn't work  link helps you learn words from a  context from a meaningful context so  just simply follow the instructions  convert the blue words to yellow words  save them don't worry about whether you  can remember them you're going to forget  them i always forget them and you'll  meet them again as yellow words but just  simply work your way through the content  creating as many links as you can saving  words so that the known words total and  your links total increases and that's an  indication that you are on your way to  learning the language